,
TO EITHER THE FUNERAL HOMES OR
TO CHURCHES OR TO THE
GRAVEYARDS.
>> ED LAVENDERA IN TEXAS, THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
>> A CALLS GROW FOR LEGISLATION
TO ADDRESS THE CRISIS OF GUN
VIOLENCE IN AMERICA, LET'S LOOK
AT HOW THE AMERICAN PEOPLE FEEL
ABOUT POTENTIAL NEW RESTRICTIONS
ON GUN OWNERSHIP.
HARRY ENTEN JOINS US FROM THE
MAGIC WALL.
THERE SEEMS TO BE A BIT OF A
DIVIDE BETWEEN THE POLLING AND
THE VOTING.
HOW PEOPLE VOTE ON SOMETHING AS
BASIC AS BACKGROUND CHECKS.
WHAT ARE YOU FINDING?
>> YEAH, LOOK, IF YOU LOOK AT
POLLING FOR SUPPORT FOR
BACKGROUND CHECKS FOR ALL GUN
BUYERS, THIS IS A QUINNIPIAC
POLL FROM LAST YEAR.
LOOK AT THIS.
89% OVERALL SAID THAT THEY WERE
FOR BACKGROUND CHECKS FOR ALL
GUN BUYERS.
98% OF DEMOCRATS, 88% OF
INDEPENDENTS, 84% OF
REPUBLICANS.
YOU BASICALLY NEVER SEE THAT
TYPE OF UNIVERSAL SUPPORT FOR
BASICALLY ANYTHING, EVEN IF THE
SKY IS BLUE.
BUT HERE'S THE THING.
POLLING IS ONE THING.
HOW PEOPLE ACTUALLY VOTE IS
SOMETHING ENTIRELY DIFFERENT
SOMETIMES.
AND SO I WANT TO GO TO THE
STATES OF MAINE AND NEVADA.
BACK IN 2016, THERE WERE BALLOT
MEASURES FOR EXPANDING
BACKGROUND CHECKS IN BOTH OF
THOSE STATES.
MAINE AND NEVADA WERE WITHIN A
POINT OF THE NATIONAL
PRESIDENTIAL VOTE THAT YEAR,
RIGHT IN THE CENTER OF THE
ELECTORATE.
WHAT HAPPENED IN MAINE AND
NEVADA?
IN MAINE, THE MEASURE TO EXPAND
BACKGROUND CHECKS GOT LESS THAN
50% OF THE VOTE.
IT FAILED.
NO ONE WITH 52% OF THE VOTE.
IN NEVADA, IT BARELY PASSED WITH
JUST A LITTLE MORE THAN 50% OF
THE VOTE.
SO FOR ME, I LOOK AT THE
POLLING.
IT SAYS ONE THING.
I LOOK AT THE ACTUAL VOTING AND
IT SHOWS A VERY DIVIDED PUBLIC,
EVEN ON SOMETHING AS SIMPLE AS
BACKGROUND CHECKS.
>> WE SHOULD REMEMBER, THE
POLLING REFLECTS THE VIEWS OF
THE PUBLIC, NOT NECESSARILY JUST
THE VIEWS OF PEOPLE WHO VOTE.
THERE IS A DIVIDE THERE.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU LOOK AT
GUN VIEWS OVERALL INSTEAD OF
SPECIFIC MEASURES?
>> YEAH, YOU KNOW, IF YOU LOOK
AT SPECIFIC MEASURES, YOU FIND
THIS VAST AMOUNT OF ARRAY FOR
BASICALLY RESTRICTING GUN
RIGHTS, BUT LOOK HERE.
ARE YOU SATISFIED WITH THE U.S.
GUN LAWS?
THIS IS A GALLUP POLL FROM LAST
YEAR.
DISSATISFIED, ONLY 36% OF
AMERICANS SAY THEY WERE
DISSATISFIED AND WANTED STRICTER
GUN LAWS.
LOOK AT THIS, THE VAST MAJORITY
SAID THEY WERE EITHER SATISFIED
OR WANTED LESS STRUCT GUN LAWS.
I LOVE THIS QUESTION BECAUSE IT
COVERS NOT ONLY VIEW BUT THE
POWER WITH WHICH PEOPLE HOLD
THEM.
HERE'S THE THING THAT I THINK
REALLY GETS AT IT.
WHICH PARTY DO YOU AGREE WITH ON
GUNS.
AN EVEN SPLIT.
38% SAY THEY AGREE MORE WITH THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY VERSUS 37% WHO
SAY THEY AGREE MORE WITH THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> REPUBLICANS IN THE 1990s WERE
MUCH MORE WILLING TO SUPPORT GUN
RESTRICTIONS.
THE 1994 ITEM BILL, IN FACT,
WHICH CONTAINED THE BAN ON SOME
SEMIAUTOMATIC ASSAULT WEAPONS,
SEMIAUTOMATIC WEAPONS, THAT BILL
WAS SUPPORTED BY 46 SENATE
REPUBLICANS.
WHAT CHANGED?
46 HOUSE REPUBLICANS.
>> THE VOTERS CHANGED.
THAT'S WHAT CHANGED.
SO LOOK AT THIS.
MORE IMPORTANT TO PROTECT RIGHT
TO OWN GUNS THAN CONTROL GUN
OWNERSHIP?
DEMOCRATS BASICALLY THE SAME,
RIGHT, 21%, 20%, 2019 VERSUS
2000.
BUT LOOK BACK IN 2000.
LESS THAN A MAJORITY OF
REPUBLICANS SAID IT WAS MORE
IMPORTANT TO PROTECT THE RIGHT
TO OWN GUNS THAN CONTROL GUN
OWNERSHIP.
NOW, 80%, THE VAST MAJORITY, SAY
IT'S MORE IMPORTANT TO PROTECT
GUN RIGHTS THAN TO OWN GUNS.
THE THING I'M LOOKING FORWARD
MOST TO IN THE MIDTERM ELECTION,
PRE-UVALDE GUN POLICY, EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT FOR CONGRESS.
MORE REPUBLICANS SAID IT THAN
DEMOCRATS.
WE'LL SEE IF THAT SWITCHES AS
THE EVENTS HAVE UNFOLDED.
>> HARRY, THANKS.
>> JOINING US NOW, DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSMAN JOE NEGUSO OF
COLORADO.
YOU JUST SAW HARRY ENTEN'S
REPORT SHOWING ABOUT AS MANY
AMERICANS TRUST REPUBLICANS AS
MUCH AS DEMOCRATS AND THE
MAJORITY ARE SATISFIED WITH THE
NATION'S CURRENT GUN LAWS OR
THINK THEY'RE TOO STRICT.
SO YOU'RE FROM COLORADO.
YOUR STATE HAS SEEN SO MANY
TERRIBLE MASS SHOOTINGS,
INCLUDING COLUMBINE IN '99.
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT SO MANY
AMERICANS DON'T SEE THIS ISSUE
THE WAY YOU DO?
>> WELL, GOOD AFTERNOON, JAKE.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME ON.
I HAVE CERTAINLY SEEN POLLING
DATA THAT SUGGESTS QUITE THE
CONTRARY AND YOUR CORRESPONDENT
WAS RIGHT ON THE FRONT END WHEN
HE TALKED ABOUT THE INDIVIDUAL
POLICIES AND PROPOSALS, FOR
EXAMPLE, UNIVERSAL BACKGROUND
CHECKS, RED FLAG LAWS, MANY
OTHERS THAT YOU HAVE OF COURSE
COVERED ON YOUR PROGRAM THAT ARE
WIDELY POPULAR AMONGST THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC, INCLUDING WITH
GUN OWNERS.
NOW, AS YOU SAID, THERE ARE SOME
STUDIES THAT SUGGEST ON MORE
BROAD QUESTIONS AROUND GUN
VIOLENCE PREVENTION THAT PERHAPS
THE DATA ISN'T AS STRONG.
OF COURSE, THAT I THINK IS IN
SOME RESPECTS A REFLECTION OF
HAVING UNADULTERED VIEWS PRIOR
TO THE CAMPAIGNS AND INFLUENCE
OF THE GUN LOBBY THAT HAS SHAPED
THE DEBATE AROUND GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION IN THE U.S.
BUT AS YOU SAID, HERE IN
COLORADO, WE ARE NO STRANGER TO
GUN VIOLENCE.
OF COURSE, THE TRAGEDY AT
COLUMBINE 23 YEARS AGO, BUT ALSO
AS YOU KNOW, JAKE, I WAS ON YOUR
PROGRAM A YEAR AGO WHEN IN
BOULDER, MY COMMUNITY, WE LOST
TEN MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY WHO
WERE GUNNED DOWN IN COLD BLOOD
AT A GROCERY STORE IN MARCH OF
2021.
MY CONSTITUENTS HAVE MADE IT
CLEAR TO ME, AND MY COLLEAGUES,
THAT INACTION ISN'T AN OPTION.
THEY EXPECT CONGRESS TO TAKE
THIS SERIOUSLY AND TREAT IT AS
THE CRISIS THAT IT IS.
I AM CONFIDENT WHILE THERE ARE
SOME WHO CERTAINLY DISAGREE WITH
DIFFERENT POLICIES OR PROPOSALS
THAT WE HAVE MADE, THAT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF AMERICANS DO AGREE
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT FOR CONGRESS
TO PASS COMMONSENSE GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION MEASURES.
>> YOUR COMMITTEE VOTED ALONG
PARTY LINES TO ADVANCE
LEGISLATION BILLED AS AN
EMERGENCY RESPONSE TO RECENT
MASS SHOOTINGS, A PACKAGE THAT
INCLUDES RESTRICTIONS ON LARGE
CAPACITY MAGAZINES, RAISES THE
AGE TO PURCHASE CERTAIN
SEMIAUTOMATIC RIFLES FROM 18 TO
21.
IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE THAT IS
LEGISLATION THAT HAS MUCH OF A
CHANCE OF GETTING THE 60 VOTES
NECESSARY IN THE SENATE TO
DEFEAT A REPUBLICAN FILIBUSTER.
>> YEAH, I THINK THAT YOUR
PROGNOSIS, JAKE, IS NOT WRONG.
I THINK OBVIOUSLY TO THE EXTENT
THAT THE HOUSE WERE TO CALIBRATE
ANY POLICIES THAT WE TAKE UP
BASED OFF WHETHER OR NOT THEY
WOULD ULTIMATELY PASS THE
SENATE, THE HOUSE WOULD NEVER
TAKE UP ANY LEGISLATION.
THE SENATE IS A VERY LETHARGIC
INSTITUTION AND THE FILIBUSTER A
HIGH BURDEN THAT UNFORTUNATELY
HAS PREVENTED, I THINK, THE
UNITED STATES CONGRESS FROM
TAKING DECISIVE ACTION ON
IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT FACE THE
PUBLIC, INCLUDING GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION.
ALL THAT BEING SAID, IT WAS
IMPORTANT, NUMBER ONE, FOR THE
HOUSE TO SHOW THAT WE'RE BEING
RESPONSIVE TO THE CONCERNS OF
THE PUBLIC, THE POLICIES THAT
YOU JUST REFERENCED WHICH ARE
PART OF THE OMNIBUS BILL WE
CONSIDERED LAST NIGHT.
AGAIN, OUR POPULAR COMMONSENSE
POLICIES.
RAISING THE AGE FROM 18 TO 21,
FOR EXAMPLE, FOR A PURCHASE OF A
SEMIAUTOMATIC RIFLE.
THE SCOURGE OF GHOST GUNS WHICH
HAVE KILLED SO MANY CITIZENS
INCLUDING MEMBERS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
ADDRESSING GHOST GUNS IN A
MATERIAL SUBSTANTIVE WAY.
THESE POLICIES ARE POPULAR.
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE HOUSE TO
TAKE THAT STEP.
I'M HOPEFUL THAT PERHAPS THOSE
WHO ARE NEGOTIATING A POTENTIAL
DEAL IN THE SENATE WILL FIND
SOME OF WHAT WE DO NEXT WEEK ON
THE FLOOR INSTRUCTIVE, AND BY
THE WAY, JAKE, I THINK WE'LL GET
SOME REPUBLICAN VOTES.
WE DIDN'T UNFORTUNATELY LAST
NIGHT IN THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE, BUT I THINK WE WILL
GET A FEW COLLEAGUES FROM THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE TO
ULTIMATELY DO THE RIGHT THING
AND STEP FORWARD AND VOTE FOR
THIS BILL WHEN IT HITS THE FLOOR
NEXT WEEK.
>> AFTER THE DISASTER AT
MARJORY
STONEMAN DOUGLAS HIGH SCHOOL IN
PARKLAND, FLORIDA, FLORIDA'S
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR RICK SCOTT
AND THE REPUBLICAN LED
LEGISLATURE DID A WHOLE BUNCH OF
THINGS INCLUDING BANNING WEAPON
SALES OF SEMIAUTOMATIC RIFLES TO
PEOPLE YOUNGER THAN 21.
THEY IMPOSED A THREE-DAY WAITING
PERIOD, CREATED A RED FLAG LAW,
DID A BUNCH OF OTHER THINGS TO
MAKE SCHOOL GROUNDS SAFER.
WHY NOT JUST TAKE THAT
LEGISLATION, COPY IT, AND OFFER
IT UP FOR A VOTE IN THE HOUSE
AND SENATE?
IT'S THE LAW IN DONALD TRUMP'S
HOME STATE.
IT WAS SIGNED BY THE REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR WHO IS NOW A SENATOR IN
CHARGE OF THE NATIONAL
REPUBLICAN SENATORIAL COMMITTEE.
WHY NOT JUST DO THAT?
>> THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION,
JAKE.
I CERTAINLY WOULD SUPPORT THAT.
I THINK THE LEGISLATION THAT WE
PASSED OUT OF THE COMMITTEE LAST
NIGHT LARGELY EMULATES MANY OF
THE PROVISIONS YOU JUST
MENTIONED.
OF COURSE, WE'RE GOING TO
CONSIDER RED FLAG LAWS
SEPARATELY NEXT WEEK, AND I
IMAGINE THOSE WERE ALSO ATTRACT
SOME BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE
HOUSE.
I'M NOT PART OF THE NEGOTIATING
GROUP IN THE UNITED STATES
SENATE.
I AM HOPING AGAINST HOPE THAT
THEY ARE SUCCESSFUL, AND I WOULD
CERTAINLY THINK THAT THE FLORIDA
TEMPLATE THAT YOU JUST
REFERENCED WHICH GARDENED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THAT STATE
WOULD BE A GOOD PLACE TO START.
ONE OF THE MOST FRUSTRATING
PARTS FOR ME PERSONALLY AND I
SUSPECT FOR SO MANY PEOPLE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY IS THE
INABILITY FOR SO MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE AISLE TO DO THE RIGHT THING
AND RECOGNIZE THAT THESE
POLICIES CAN IN FACT SAVE LIVES
AND THEY'RE